hey what is going on everybody so
today's video is going to be a little
different if you noticed there is going
to be no background music there's going
to be no funny cuts or anything like
that this is just about an event that I
threw in a conversation that I had with
30 people that RSVP'd to the event to
come and train with me and also open up
and talk about their struggles with
fitness and this event turned out to be
something that was extremely
enlightening and there's a message in
here that I think that everybody should
listen to when it comes to fitness or
just their approach on life so I hope
you guys enjoy the video and let me know
if you like him
I wanted to do a group activity thing
because what I realized that every time
I like message somebody or I had a
conversation with somebody when it came
to like their level of fitness a lot of
it had to do with people being a little
bit scared especially when you guys do
something like kickboxing or boxing it's
a little intimidating right I think the
biggest fallacy that a lot of people
have when they try to do something you
guys expect yourself to be experts right
what you do it and then there's the
complete opposite of what you should
think when you try something the first
time you do it if you don't look dumb
well [ __ ] you I don't know how you did
you know I don't know how you [ __ ]
hit it I even till this day like Nick
and I when we do our training sessions I
record myself in my mind I look like me
women I record myself and then I delete
it and I like these type of group
activities because number one it teaches
you that you're also in the same
position that somebody else is in we
have this like problem where we expect
ourselves to be great and excellent as
something without actually having tried
it first you're not supposed to be great
at everything that you just start I
don't ever want you guys to look at
somebody else's say well how come I'm
not as good as then you just need to be
better at what you do every day and
that's why I said it's very important
for you guys to really really just start
with the foundation and a habit even the
way you guys worked out today you don't
have to do this every
you hit on me and if you're doing it
everyday well go join the Olympics here
in the rom professor think about what
you guys want out of this
you know I'll use it I'll use somebody
and I have a friend right now he lost
about like a hundred pounds right I'm
super problem I'm very happy for him and
the the troubling thing that I think
that I've seen with a lot of people not
not him specifically but a lot of people
who have lost weight around me they they
go to Instagram they take this photo and
they post it up and they see their likes
and they're like awesome like people
like the fact that I lost weight cool
they do it again the next week the
lights go down a little bit wait three
the lights go down again he goes hey I'm
still transforming I'm still fit guys
and then waiting for somebody to say hey
you're awesome you're awesome you're
great you're great the problem with that
is you don't believe it yourself I don't
have enough likes as I did before so I
have to do a different picture to get
more likes and the reason why is because
he never liked himself in the first
place and he's waiting for somebody else
to tell him that he's amazing after you
lose this weight whatever fitness school
that you get when you go home and the
next day and you feel that same
experience that he's feeling you kind of
[ __ ] up because what's gonna happen is
after you get your fitness goal you're
just regular you you're not fat gym fat
any whatever that became skinny fit
Betty skinny fit Jim you're just you and
you got to live with that every day so
if you're still looking to impress
somebody else through your fitness and
showing everybody else to the Instagram
whatever social media that stuff is
gonna faint real [ __ ] fast
and it'll just be you and you'll still
be stuck with the same way that you felt
when you were big even when you're fit
it's a much of a mental game as it is
when it comes to that fitness thing too
so that's why you guys always see on my
channel almost like yo just just [ __ ]
appreciate yourself first because that's
gonna be the biggest part that's gonna
be the thing that's gonna get you up
every morning to get you to go to class
to go to more time to go to boxing
because you know what sometimes when
somebody pushes you you're gonna resist
you're gonna tell like y'all amen I just
want to chill I'm happy with the way
that I am and if you are that's
perfectly fine but the reason why you're
here is because you want to change
something about yourself
you have to be honest with yourself
first if you're not honest with yourself
you could lie to yourself every [ __ ]
day for the rest of your life and the
next thing you know you're 50 years old
sisters or you're talking about what
could have been and what I wanted and I
don't want that for you guys at this
point right what I want to do if any of
you guys are like open to doing it and I
think this is a very therapeutic part
about like fitness is I'm gonna ask
right now and if anybody wants to share
what what was the biggest reason for you
guys to come here today aside just from
you don't meet my fine ass you ain't
gotta believe it but I do this is where
I hold my pens right here so anybody
want to share like their like personal
fitness goals that they have any kind of
struggles that they had with their
fitness whether it's like getting
stronger losing weight yes so I actually
moved past my original weight loss goal
so my original weight loss goal was just
to be at 220 pounds I'm actually at 210
right now I'm actually happy with this
weight like that my problem was a little
different than everybody else is because
like I felt like a lot of the people
that were trying to lose weight they
didn't like the way that they look I had
like the opposite of body dysmorphia I
was like I woke up every day I was like
well you are fit I was like damn dude
look at those ABS that chest muscle and
then my girlfriend would be like eh you
kind of breathe heavy all the time like
Oh would you Donna I'm perfectly fine
and I would wear my shirts and I'm like
dude man they don't make my XL like they
used to and I would blame my clothes
itself I would blame my dryer I'm like
do these Samsung's write these Korean
people anymore
and you know I started to realize that
there was sit around like look at these
fat people they're so out of shape my
prom is look at me like dude you're fat
like you're out of shape I'm what do you
mean and then you know it started
happening when Mike Mike joints started
to hurt I was like my knee started to
hurt and my back was hurting again and I
had to sit down for a second I was like
yo I love myself but and my factors like
I had like I had a really big of I was
like am I out of shape I went to get
something called a DEXA scan and it
showed that I had like 38 percent body
fat blew my [ __ ] mind
I was like dude that should been a solid
six percent so yeah I moved past my goal
and am I at a plateau right now I'm kind
of happy where I'm at so if I lose more
weight which I guess like my my goal
that I my new goal will be at like 190
pounds if I get there why not
but right now I have a really healthy
relationship with food and fitness I'm
at 210 if I go down to 190 I'm happy if
I don't I'm still good
bro
you know take my my doing what's you
become part of the 75th Ranger this is
the reason why I always come back to
YouTube like I don't need you to come
you know I don't need it for increment I
do because I like I do because I enjoy
what I do
I do it because even though I don't get
millions of views whatever a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand views I
get to connect with people like you
that's all that really matters
I don't need it but I want and that's
what I had to come back to you that's
why I love stories like that man
I came here today because I'm an
introvert because I was always the
unpopular one where I wasn't going up
with a group like I'll be part of the
group but they know ok you know I was
just always on the outside of the group
so that's how I grew up and then I
haven't talked to people and like over
two years it was just me and my
boyfriend that's it every day every day
and then I but I love people I love to
help people and that's who I am
and I also plan on going to the US Army
but I wanted to do combat medic and I
came in today because I feel like as a
team of military and wanting to be a
combat medic your chain guys were like
six feet tall weighing 200 and you're
like 150 you know so I can't wait today
to put myself that you can't do it and
you don't have to be afraid you've even
being a combat medic I wanted to prove
to you and prove to the fellow soldiers
that you may look at me I become small
but I'm gonna take care of you so I can
trade in a food to myself back
and to remind myself that if you want to
make in the military you have to
surround yourself with people you have
to rely on people so I came out here to
stop being extroverted and I wanted to
say thank you I've been watching you
from day one on YouTube and you every
time I get really really sad I just
watch your videos and all the suicidal
thoughts just go away
[Applause]
personal demons you know and whether you
choose to address it or not it's always
gonna be there and you're gonna find
yourself at a point to but you're gonna
have to address them
and it was hard for me to I didn't want
to address it I always meet it in my
humor like you know I look like a ghetto
ass area everybody clowns on everybody
like the way I speak is not unique to
myself all my friends talk like this you
know and the cool thing is like for me
it's like you got fat jokes and what you
got that boy I always told myself do God
made me sad because I'm too cute and
everything else I think that's what I
really liked about you know kickboxing -
it was it was so [ __ ] hard you know
and to really I mean to wake up every
day and do something that's like
physically taxing was something that I
didn't appreciate because it helped me
like become a better person in the sense
of like mentally you know what I mean it
showed me that yo even though it
sometimes you feel like you can't do it
at least when you show up you can always
prove yourself wrong and every day I
know myself wrong like hey you're not
that person you were with the day before
come in even sometimes Vic knows like
when we train sometimes I come a little
late because I wake up and I'm on my
phone trying to give an excuse
you know that's what he knows too but
then eventually what happens is I get
myself out of bed I tell us that they'll
make those excuses and even as I'm
driving I knew like three circles around
don't go in go ahead I'm hoping like the
nail catches my tire or something you
doubted me but you know that you know
the truth comes out
you know like in my videos I always talk
about like pumping yourself up because
sometimes do some other people aren't
gonna do it for you like it's hard
happiness takes effort if people don't
realize that [ __ ] as as much as sadness
like takes effort happiness takes effort
- I'm happy because I put the effort to
be happy every day it takes work
everything that you want and like takes
work you know I was broke when I came to
city man I sold everything that I had to
come here just so I could chase
something that I didn't know I could
make a paycheck
I don't know YouTube you can make money
I just thought yo if I do this platform
everybody saw me make one this one white
girl and now I could be a dope-ass
stand-up comedian and that's all I bet
it on and I just worked hard towards it
and then later on it cut it
into something else with a taco my
favorite pastime is watching this child
check out this man not only for fitness
but mainly for that child that is the
cutest baby I've ever seen
Heiko you've got competition
[Music]